it's election season in nairobi
[Music]
and billboards usually reserved for
attracting customers are now selling
dreams of progress to potential voters
made the best my way
the race is on for every position of
political power in the country and two
front runners are vying for the top spot
ryla odinga former prime minister and
son of one of kenya's founding fathers
is up against william ruto the current
deputy president and self-proclaimed
hustler
and it's only a matter of days before
kenyans cast their final vote
all we want is bread on the table kenya
is awakening
in makuru one of the largest slums in
nairobi we meet chris
he's a midwife supporting new mothers
here and with costs of living soaring
many of them are now struggling to get
by
he takes us to meet one of the women
ruth
she's packed and ready to leave the
capital until the dust settles millions
have been impacted by election violence
here in the past and ruth is scared
where is the fear coming from
the election
okay like last last time
had fight
but so you don't know this yeah what
will happen
in terms of how much you're bringing in
do you are you able to pay for
consistent food and not that much
just a little for a day then you pray
god the following day we get another
issue
there's an urgent need for this election
to pass calmly
but temperatures are high on both sides
may the best candidate win but i believe
in raila he will win soon
that's my president i mean it feels
tense it feels divided but people are
insisting that no matter what happens
they'll examine their results
[Music]
are welcome
but it can't drown out the uncertainty
the more you're nearing the election i
have a bad feeling about it i don't know
why but it's like intuitively feeling
concerned as long as any leader wins i'm
going to go with it we just draw it
what we ask for is just people to be
peaceful let's just have
[Music]
the open wounds of past elections
soothed by a healthy dose of optimism
just
sky news nairobi